Bladesmiths, this
is the sharpness test.
To see how sharp the edge of
your friction folders are,
I will take your fiction folder
and deliver some ham slices.
Greg, you're up first.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
That's deep.
Well, Greg, your
blade is very sharp.
Your friction folder
will cut the job.
Jacob, you're next.
You ready?
Yep.
[music playing]
Well, Jacob, your
blade cuts well,
but it's kind of
blocky to hold on to.
Overall, though,
your edge will cut.
Good job.
Thank you.
Flood, you ready?
I'm absolutely ready.
[music playing]
Ham slices, anyone?
The minute I grabbed onto the
handle, it did all the work.
Your blade, sir, will cut.
Thank you.
Bladesmiths, welcome
to our strength test,
the green bamboo chop.
I'm going to take each
your friction folders,
and I'm going to
very violently strike
into this very tough
bamboo 10 times.
I don't really care what
your knives do to the bamboo.
I want to see what the bamboo
is going to do to your knives.
Greg, you're up first.
You want to have some fun?
Yup.
Let's do it.
[music playing]
Well, Greg, we've got
some edge damage here.
You've got a very,
very fine edge, which
we saw on the sharpness test.
But this whole
section right here now
is rolled over back and forth.
It was comfortable in the hand.
And having that long
tail in your tang there
allowed me to reach down
further and actually
generate more velocity.
You got edge damage, but
other than that, good job.
Thank you.
Jacob, you ready?
[music playing]
OK, Jacob.
Your edge held up fine.
You got that nice,
steep grind on there.
That worked very well.
It's proportionately awkward.
Holding onto it, it's
covering my entire palm here.
So it's a little
tough to hold on to.
But the blade held
up beautifully.
Nice job.
Thank you.
Flood.
I'm curious to
see what happens.
So am I. Let's find out.
[music playing]
Flood, this is a
beautiful piece.
Thank you.
I see what Doug meant.
As soon as you
pick it up, you can
index it perfectly right where
the sweet spot is to hold it.
Your edge, after that,
is still razor sharp.
Bladesmiths, the judge's
deliberation is complete.
They've made their
final decision.
The Bladesmith
leaving the forge is--
Greg, your blade did
not make the cut.
Greg, you've got
a great design there
and a comfortable handle.
But what it came down to
is the significant edge
damage your blade took
during the strength test.
And that's why we're
letting you go.
Greg, please
surrender your weapon.
I wish I would
have put a little bit
better geometry on my blade to
make it better for chopping.
But I feel like I
represented myself very well
as a craftsman, and I kept
a good head on my shoulders
throughout the
whole competition.
My plan for the future is to
make some high-quality blades
and potentially apply
from my journeyman test.
But the first thing I'm
going to do when I get home
is drink a beer and take a nap.